thank you so much Rick for being here
today as you can see we've got a lot of
really interested people in the audience
here for the first view from the top of
the year so thanks to everybody for
being here you and I had a chance last
week to grab coffee and I walked away
from that conversation feeling really
excited about what we were going to talk
about here today I think you've got an
incredible story to share about
leadership at Yale which I'm sure
everybody's heard of then going into
your recent transition to Coursera which
is one of the most buzzed-about
companies in education today
and lastly your thoughts on leadership
generally and advice that you have about
lessons you've learned from your career
and thoughts you have to share with our
student community here so I'd love to
get started by stepping back to 1993
when you were first appointed president
of Yale and in a lot of ways this was a
little bit of a turnaround situation you
had a very significant operating deficit
of about 20 million dollars you liked a
lot of the time oh a lot of the time a
lot now you had strained relationships
with the faculty and I think there were
a lot of questions at that time about
where Yale was going in the future so
how did you step into that role as
president what were your priorities as
you thought about your strategy to
address these issues well you know
looking back it was surprising to see
that the the the major initiatives that
I laid out in my inaugural address
turned out to be the things that
occupied me for 20 years
so it some of it was not rocket science
so it was pretty obvious we we had a
really terribly crumbling physical
infrastructure most of yell was built in
the interwar period between World War 1
and World War 2 and in collegiate Gothic
style and had not been touched since
1945 so or 40 so there was basically
massive amounts of investment needed to
bring the infrastructure up to decent
condition and that that sort of decaying
look of the campus
and the problematic nature of the city
of New Haven which at the time with very
high unemployment had the whole central
business district essentially one-third
vacant where crime was was rampant at an
all-time high all of these things were
causing us to lose market share for the
best students in in higher education and
so it was it was you know at the edge of
the best in the cut in the world but it
risk of falling out of that very top
tier of universities and so investment
in both infrastructure and the city were
just looming large as powerful things
that needed to be addressed and then
there are a couple of things I saw at
that time that were longer-term that
turned out to be major themes one was
internationalization as your Dean laid
out and thank you by the way Garth for
that generous undeserved introduction
but one was internationalization because
I just thought the world was changing
and globalization people weren't using
the word yet in 1993 but but but the
phenomenon was clear I mean we needed
Tom Friedman to give us the words but we
but we had the song somehow and and and
then the other was redressing the
balance of Yale's strengths and
weaknesses that is we had we were in
danger of becoming a so tilted towards
the humanities the social science and
the professions and weaker and weaker in
science medicine and engineering I felt
we needed to sort of put more balance
into that mix a lesson by the way which
Stanford should learn in the other
direction if you want my advice but we
do yeah so so those were the those are
the big themes and the first initially
the first really major steps were taken
toward urban citizenship in New Haven
which was a major project and tell us
about that you know what did you learn
about working with the the city at that
time and also pitching that to your
board and trying to get buy-in for that
effort
yeah the board was there because the
board was very nervous about the the the
sort of reputation of New Haven is a
dangerous place and so they were
entirely on board with with investing
significantly in this
it was more a question of selling the
faculty and the and the local
constituents who felt you know if Yale
starts spending money to help fix New
Haven this was like pouring money down
the drain
and and so we didn't start by spending
money we started by by doing other
things so that the idea was it we had a
two hundred plus year history of
town-gown rivalry ill-will Yale had was
this rich ivory tower institution in a
poor and declining industrial city that
you know they had been a prosperous
industrial city but was was in was any
great decline was as manufacturing
industry went away the shirt making
industry went to the south the munitions
industry at the end of the Vietnam War
basically shut down and there was
nothing left really nothing left
literally it was awful so so we had to
we needed if we you know we knew what
the economic development was going to be
a major theme but we couldn't just jump
into that we were did we were not
trusted so the issue was winning a bona
fides of community leaders of the
political apparatus and of the other
community organizations in the
neighborhoods and in the clergy who had
important political influence
particularly the black community so we
we we said about it by with volunteerism
I'm really mobilizing the late what was
already happening but organizing it in
much more systematic ways so I basically
I made I had every Dean of every school
rec you know told that it's part of your
job description to have urban outreach
and you get your students and faculty
involved so the Drama School was doing
improv theaters and the near not nearby
neighborhood and the forestry
environmental study school was planning
trees and creating pocket parks and
neighborhoods and and we can go on and
on all kinds of initiatives on parts of
students and faculty and and after a
couple years that it really helped we
were really kind of beginning to win the
hearts and minds
hey Yale's different now it's really
engaged in helping the city in and being
a participating citizen and it was only
at that point that the mayor came to me
and said you know we need to fix the
downtown and the only the only entity in
the place with cap with the capital and
the vision and the self-interest
make that work is Yael so with my
blessing go ahead and buy downtown and
redevelop it and I mean that was amazing
historian from a historical point of
view that we had that opportunity but it
worked out really well and we've got
great retail great great food you know
really terrific restaurants in downtown
New Haven now it's actually truthfully I
hate to say this but it's actually nicer
than Harvard Square
we won't compare but you know I think
one thing that you were saying Rick that
you know this this idea of how you work
with the faculty at your school I think
is really interesting faculty are
generally tenured you can't fire them
you can't force them to do what you want
so how did you go about creating a
vision and getting them to to really
have a consensus on that well this is
this is all true for almost any
constituency where you need their
support I mean this would be true to any
of you who are leading organizations and
you want to keep the you know your
senior staff with you you want to keep
the employees with you basically a
leader needs to articulate a vision it
needs to be clearly and coherently
articulated it needs to be tested with
key people at the beginning before it's
widely communicated but then it's
communicate communicate communicate I
mean it's just getting the message out
and and going and patiently talking
about it with skeptical audiences
answering questions being being open and
responsive to suggestions and change but
also not yielding on the core vision and
you know one of the great things about
faculty is they're basically rational
and even though they're very independent
and so persuasion is possible actually
if you have if you you know if it's a
compelling argument eventually you'll
win and and that I think that's that's
that was the wit that you know for
things like you know investing in the
infrastructure rebuilt you know
investing in the city and
internationalization all of those
strategies really became I think of
pretty common consensus with time
patience
explanation lots of meetings with groups
to talk it through
on the topic of internationalization you
did face some pushback on the decision
by the university to open a campus in
Singapore in partnership with the
National University of Singapore there
was a lot of question around whether
Yale should be partnering with a country
that had some questionable stands on
human rights in conflict with the way
Yale felt and so how did you make that
decision to really put yourself behind
that decision when you knew there was
gonna be public outcry right well so the
initiative to start a liberal arts
college in Singapore came very you know
rather late in my presidency we started
talking about it in spring of 2009 after
they'd been in my position for nearly 16
years and and it was it was the kind of
a capstone of a major effort to do a lot
of other things globally lots of
exchange programs research facilities in
China all kinds of other things have
preceded this so the actual
internationalization battle for hearts
and minds within the university had
already been won well people would hit
the nerve of some of our faculty and I
you know I hate the leaders will always
say this but it was a really small
minority of people who were really
exercised about this the majority as one
fact was won one of my key advisors one
faculty member who I greatly respect
said to me about this before it blew up
he said he said you know the thing is
you've got 15 percent of the people
wildly enthusiastic about this and five
percent or are just really upset about
it and the remaining 80 percent actually
don't know or care or that's totally
indifferent you said what do you have to
avoid is a situation where the five
percent somehow get an issue where they
can bring where they can persuade the 80
percent well that was so precious
because it turned out to be what
happened but the the these faculty
members tried to pass a resolution that
said we fit you know we support full
human rights in Singapore well who's
gonna vote against of that right so it
was it was it was not that they censored
are doing it it was not a vote of
no-confidence than are doing it it was
very clever and
and you know so we took a few lumps in
the press on this let me tell you why
this is such a great idea though Asia is
crying out for the kind of critical
pedagogy that focuses on critical
thinking you know China trains
enormous numbers of Engineers and we
Americans warrior they're gonna eat our
lunch someday because of this and they
look at us and they say but all the
innovation in the world is coming from
the United States and why they have a
very different method of educating
people they teach people to think for
themselves to be independent to question
the teacher to speak up in class to
argue we need more event and so the
Chinese were kind of begging me to do
this to set up the liberal arts college
within China I thought that was an
environment where it just wasn't ready
for for this kind of really free free
ranging intellectual battles and
questioning Authority but Singapore
frankly for all the reputation of the
they're trying to maintain a kind of
tenuous hold on on what is a potentially
an island a multicultural island in the
middle of you know of a very very
different you know
ethnic composition on Malaysia and China
nearby you know yes the government's
been authoritarian in many ways and
freedoms that we that we would like to
and we enjoy are not present entirely
there but the universities had always
been in Singapore a kind of Oasis where
the rules are different and where free
speech goes on where academic freedom is
practiced and friends of ours said look
this if you are negotiating an
arrangement with the Singaporeans you
can trust them to abide by the they'll
do they'll be straight if you write it
down in a contract they'll honor it and
so we wrote at we wrote a great contract
which essentially protects academic
freedom on the campus it doesn't protect
students who want to go march on the
public in the public square downtown
because that's not allowed and saying if
we have to have a permit but but we can
we had them define our campus as an
indoor space so
was one it was one way runs and just
just a few weeks ago there was a there
was a good example of this a film with
which is politically critical of the of
the ruling party was released in Europe
and it was banned in for public
exhibition in Singapore but before the
public ban occurred we had already
assured been assured by the government
that yes consistent with with our
understanding you can show this on your
campus so so we're think we've
negotiated a pretty reasonable
arrangement and by the way but it's an
incredible the students were getting are
amazing the curriculum is a prescribed
curriculum that in the first year that
compares Eastern and Western
intellectual traditions in social
thought in literature and looks at
comparative social institutions it's
really a radically different kind of
curriculum and we're you it's all small
classes all 15 or 18 students at most
and it's going great I want to go back
to Asia in a little bit once we move
into your time at Coursera because I
know that's a big a big market for you
there as well but after 20 years at Yale
you ended up retiring in 2013 that
didn't last very long first course I
ever flunked his retirement exactly so
so I'm curious you you went from Yale
where you had you know almost 20 billion
dollar endowment and twelve thousand
students to Coursera where you have 85
million dollars in venture capital and
nine million users at this point I don't
know the ten ten million users at this
point so growing exponentially that's a
that's a huge change for you what made
you think Coursera is the next step for
me well I didn't think it when I when I
left you a lie as president I was out
here visiting as a visiting professor in
economics that oversee per and kind of
thought I'd construct the life with a
portfolio of things to do like maybe
some maybe go back to do some teaching
either at Stanford Grail or maybe half
and a half and and and then I would you
know be on a couple boards and do some
public service
Commission's and studies and things like
that so I you know I could see a pretty
full life ahead but then I somehow just
you know ran into the folks at Kleiner
Perkins and and was convinced you know
go go go take a look at this and I went
over it and signed on as you know to be
a consultant essentially come a week a
month in this last spring semester and
and I basically got seduced you know
they basically pitch me on actually we
could you know we have wonderful
co-founders or Stanford professors
they're brilliant magnet of innovative
but we could use a CEO could help take
this to the next level and so I
succumbed and I must say it's more
consistent with what I've been doing for
the last decade or even even 12 14 years
then I would have initially thought that
is I've the big focus on
internationalization one and also Yale
did play an early role in online
education we we started with Stanford as
a joint venture Stanford Oxford and Yale
we did a little startup in 2000 called
all learned there was an aesthetic
success but a financial flop we had the
wrong market we you know that's one
amazing thing about technology I mean we
just we we were stumbling like every all
people at the beginning and we thought
this was really for our alumni well it's
much too narrow a market segment so Yale
Stanford and Oxford were putting on
these great courses targeting their
alumni just we're just weren't getting
the enrollments and sustaining it but
men and oh seven we started with open
educational resources and like MIT we
put a large number of our best courses
online but not interactively not like
Coursera not like the current mark
Luke's was just a camera in the back of
the classroom you know capturing the
lectures and that was that was great it
got a lot of viewership but nothing like
course I mean Coursera and Udacity and
EDX started to operate you could see
that the world had changed the internet
bandwidth was now now supported
large-scale interactivity and it's so
this is this is an amazing opportunity
to democratize higher education I mean
the reason I'm doing it is not not the
reason that most pres
and Provost's will tell you that they
are doing it most of them will tell you
the main reason main thing that's in it
for me is I can improve on campus
teaching they get all this data on what
works and what doesn't work and I can
use it at home but to me that's like
saying the automobile when it was
invented was a good tool for going to
the grocery store you know I mean it's
it's it misses the point that that the
that the scale itself is unbelievably
powerful and the idea that a single
Stanford professor a single Yale
professor would teach a class one class
for ten weeks or eight weeks and teach
more students in that class than they
would teach in a 30 or 40 year teaching
career at home is amazing it's taking
the resources that we that we
universities invest in great teachers
developing their careers becoming
masters of a subject becoming experts
and giving that expertise to the world
for free I mean it's truly revolutionary
and and that's what's exciting that it
is very exciting but how how are you
thinking about the research Ric that
shows that the primary users of of MOOCs
at this point are college educated white
males that that's sort of as contradict
contradictory to the goal that you have
to provide access to millions of users
and learners worldwide so how are you in
course they are thinking about that
issue the we are doing all we can to
promote outreach to the populations that
wouldn't normally have access to this
but that is to say I mean sort of
naturally you'd expect highly educated
affluent people later in life to sample
these courses that's sort of obvious
you're all going to do it when you're
when you're looking for something
interesting to do when you're 50 years
old you know apart from your job but the
but the but but there's you know a
couple of things
so you it's not surprising as
penetration there but there's a amazing
amount of penetration elsewhere I mean
what does it mean to be to have a
college degree if you're if you're from
a developing country with low per capita
incomes it probably it doesn't mean the
same thing in terms of what you've been
exposed
- as if you've gone to an Ivy League
school or a Stanford or a first-rate
institution in Europe I mean we are
giving a lot of value to people even if
they're college educated in places where
what they got in college is nothing like
what you you all got so that's one - is
we are using various tools like creating
live learning hubs in US embassies
around the world so where people who
don't have the bandwidth can actually
come and get access to it and and have
have sort of mentored discussion groups
the State Department is very excited
about this as an outreach there's an OP
getting to people in Africa and the
Middle East and that's so that's
underway so they're you know it's going
to spread and also cell phone technology
is getting bandwidth is getting better
and better in these developing countries
and we're we're now optimizing for
mobile use I mean originally we
regionally four months ago we as we put
we put the lectures only the videos on
on mobile applications and now we
realize people are using it 30% of our
of our viewership is our students are
now accessing via their iPads or their
tablets or their phones and so now we're
developing by the middle and next year
we'll have completely full interactivity
everything you can do on a computer
you'll be able to do on the phone how
are you thinking about who your main
customer is because you've got the
universities on the one side that are
putting their content up on your
platform you've got the students who are
using it and you also have the business
community where you have an opportunity
to provide support in terms of
credentialing so how are you thinking
about those various strategies are you
sort of executing on all of those at
this point or do you believe like Steve
Ballmer does that you need one strategy
and you need to do it really well
well we couldn't succeed by ignoring all
three pieces of that of that triangle
that is we obviously need to appeal to
we have to optimize for the learner
experience that it has to be a really
attractive
presentation of the material if there is
to be something people want to reengage
in after they try it so that's that's
just a product design and and good
pedagogy and using the research from all
the data that to make the user
experience better we have to please our
partners because our as this is Coursera
specific now because you wouldn't have
to go this way but our niche in this
market is aggregating content from great
universities many of the other people in
the online education space are using
faculty they hire freelance which are
largely from industry not from
universities and that's and four sort of
business skills training that's probably
a pretty successful model it's basically
what you dasa T is doing they're
focusing narrowly on the tech sector
hiring industry people to teach courses
on tech skills our niche and our asset
is relationships with now 128
universities who are the best in the
world and I think you know it makes us
different it it makes the average
quality of what we do way higher I think
than any of the competitors and and so
we need to keep a heart and the partners
happy and then the business community
comes in because we need people to
recognize I mean our monetization
strategy is basically the education is
free but if you want verification
verified you know your identity verified
and get certified as having completed
the course satisfactorily that cost 50
dollars basically and we now are
discounting the price in some developing
countries and to do that you need
business you know for that to be
something that people want to pay for
when it's also free you need the
business community to recognize some of
these courses about half of our courses
or build skills the other half are
general education courses though at
least those half of the courses that the
business me says oh yes we want people
who've taken your data science
specialization or we want people who
have studied Android programming on your
on your platform I want to make sure to
spend some time Rick on the fact that
you went from really leading a roomful
of PhD academics to looking out at a
roomful of MBAs and product engineers
right
so how has your leadership style evolved
since moving from a very traditional
university into a start-up where you're
not only dealing with a different type
of employee but you're also dealing with
two founders who still are very involved
with the company it's great there's a
lot it's different that's for sure but
you know as a general as a general
matter there's a lot that's in common in
any leadership position and and I said
it you know having a vision
communicating it clearly picking the
right people putting them in the right
jobs enabling them not micromanaging
them you know those are all lessons that
are very very general and and and you
know running Coursera's sort of more a
little more it's somewhere in between
sort of more like running the Economics
Department than like running Yale
because it's a it's a it's a smaller
population of people and the economics
part we had about my time about 50
faculty and 30 or 40 staff so it of
course a little bit smaller than
Coursera but and so you know you have
all hands meetings you deal with the
whole population you didn't do that in
the big organization like Yale so you
need to have you know the ability to
listen and process and organize people
delegate tasks the right people all
that's the same what's kind of different
is the speed of the the required speed
of decision making I'm in this in this
internet environment I mean we're in a
brand-new startup business we're
constantly testing and iterating we have
to do our product development rapidly
you know put something out there try it
do some testing improve it cut we're
just working relentlessly you know day
and night to make the product better and
better and make the feat build new
features make them make them work that's
just a relentless effort on a time scale
with just higher pressure than you're
used to in a university setting and then
there's questions about making strategic
choices you know they're coming at you
all the time and just as they are in the
university in the university you know
everybody's used to
let's talk about this for three months
before you decide I mean it's just
there's not that sense of urgency you're
well resourced you basically the
business of daily education and research
is going to go on no matter what the
President does and and so it's different
but in the small company in a highly
competitive environment where we're
charting new ground you have to be
prepared to react more quickly and and
and actually that means be prepared to
make a few mistakes because you can't
get everything right without a lot of
deliberation so you you take some risks
that's what makes the world interesting
can you share any of those risks that
you've taken that haven't gone so well
well we haven't made any of those bad
decisions since I've been there but
there were some in there I think there
we have we have tried to work with our
partners the universities to renegotiate
certain aspects of our arrangements with
them and we've run into situations where
they've been very adamant about
maintaining one or two of the terms in
our original agreement which I fully
understand why it recognizes their
interests but on the other hand you know
it's it's not consistent with sort of
internet norms we're an Internet company
and there are there are what happens
here's a good example what happened this
is one we've just had a hard time we
would like to do more to essentially be
able to take down comments on this on
our in our interactions on our forums
when if they're if they start to get
harassing or threatening or or or are
and we've had some bad you know there's
some bad bad actors we've had incidents
that are bad incidents and you know the
university perspective is we don't take
anything down we just we just you know
we we and certainly with my policy at
Yale if you know hate speech is
responded to with more speech you
basically use it as a teaching moment
you tell if community
this is inappropriate but we're not
gonna - we're not gonna take it you know
we're not gonna take it down but we're
but we're gonna tell you we think this
is inappropriate and here's why the
Internet's not like that all the big
social media places you know are taking
stuff down all the time
and and you know so Kenny the
universities really aren't ready to
accept that they want they want the
university kind of rules to govern and
they don't want it Coursera taking
anything down without their involvement
and so we made a we made a kind of a
mistake reaching for this I think that
we've backed off and okay we won't do
anything without talking to you first
but it's just a way it's kind of
give-and-take you see in these kinds of
situations
you've got a room full of potential
entrepreneurs here as well as people who
have a real passion for education so
outside of what Coursera is doing what
do you see as the the biggest
opportunity for disruption in education
today and what advice would you have for
the students here on how to pursue those
opportunities
demeans yes this new technology does
have the potential to disrupt higher
education but I think actually the
near-term phenomenon that the phenomenon
for the next decade won't be that
universities as we know them disappear
it'll be that universities actually have
their impact amplified and and and
become more important to society by
virtue of having even more people you
know that they're engaged with so that's
one thing but what but what in it what
an EdTech I mean you know the promise
that EdTech is gonna deliver miracles
has been around for a long time I
remember when I started teaching as an
assistant professor at Yale all the
excitement about what Carnegie Mellon
then called programmed learning that you
know we're gonna replace lectures
entirely with computer drills that are
exactly all print based that you know
just basically take you through material
in a programmed way and if you get a
wrong answer here it leads you in this
branch and you get the following
material and get a right answer it goes
to this path
and it that never happened it's still a
good idea I mean a modern version of
this would be an idea I had at Yale
actually that we couldn't get high
school teachers to accept which was we
wanted to do it have Yale press do a
really first-rate Chinese language you
know teaching Chinese to English
language learners and my idea was gamify
it you know it's basically have have
voice recognition technology and have
you and have you say something you
confronted obstacle and in a game you
know and and you have to communicate the
words you know orally and that and the
computer would fix I thought that would
be a great way to teach you know did you
find high school the high school
teachers we consulted with didn't want
to even touch it you know so it's gonna
be a long time before there's really
revolutionary disruption in traditional
education in the meantime all this stuff
added around the fringes is gonna like
like MOOCs for university level stuff
and like of those Khan Academy material
and other things that focus more on K to
12 I think can be greatly enriching for
people it's gonna make their lives
better I think it I think it's creating
great social value I mean I'd encourage
you to think about you know joining us
startup and and trying to help build
something the idea that we're gonna
completely disrupt the educational
system as opposed to just reaching more
people who are outside it or improving
the experience of those are inside it is
probably just a little early well I've
been speaking a lot here and asking you
a lot of questions Rick so I want to
make sure to open it up to our audience
and we have two mics that will be passed
as well as our hashtag GSB vft t so
we'll be alternating between questions
from the audience here and questions
that Ryan will read from Twitter so Ryan
do you have one ready to go sure yeah so
we've gotten a few questions from the
audience on on Coursera and on your role
at Yale and one that keeps up that you
might have an interesting perspective on
is what's your pitch to colleges or
universities is it solely about
amplifying the message of universities
how do you deal with the threats they
they perceive Coursera or MOOCs having
to the traditional model and is there a
place for a sort of a moral
responsibility of universities to
provide education of the masses yeah so
that it I mean the scale that this
offers has been my my principle pitch so
universities in it's actually a huh it's
actually a kind of a hard sell I mean
it's not it's I think part of what I
what I have to do personally is is to
carry that message I mean I I think that
it's that and one of the advantages of
having been a university president and
dealing now with university leaders is I
do have some credibility so people are
kind of surprised when I say my first
you know the first the the first thing
about this is not improving on campus
teaching although it's great for that
and it will help you do that if you if
that's what you focus on you're sort of
missing what's really what really
matters so I have been pushing primarily
the notion that this should redefine the
mission of the university our mission
the mission of the university if you go
to most people's mission statements well
have something to do with the creation
and the dissemination of knowledge okay
so we create knowledge through our
research we disseminate it through our
publications and teaching what we
publish to increasingly small audiences
you know I mean many professionals
publish their articles and we're read by
you know a hundred people in their field
and that's pretty good we disseminate it
through teaching okay and the teaching
in many places like GSB is wonderful but
how big are the classes and how many
students do there's a professor reach
this offers an OP you know you know on
average maybe a hundred or 200 students
a year is that is the nut amount of
contact a faculty member has and where
the Corsair of course you reach tens of
thousands and and that's revolutionary I
think it gives the university a chance
to make a difference to you know global
development to give economic opportunity
to people all over the world and to give
lifelong learning opportunity to those
who you know don't need the economic
advancement but mr. curious just one
want to grow so it's an amazing I think
it's amazing that that is basically my
pitch I mean yes will support your
on-campus flipped classrooms I mean it's
great it's yes we'll give you data you
can analyze it you can figure out which
questions in your quizzes are not
working and you can improve your
lectures that lead up to those questions
if there's a whole lot of things we can
do that way and yes we can generate
revenue for you but frankly we think we
can at least but frankly that revenue is
not the scale at which we can do that is
not going to be a game-changer for a
hundred and twenty eight different
University partners I mean if we had
even if we were distributing half a
billion dollars that's not a huge number
for universities you know to have so I
think it's mainly this it's mainly think
about what what is the social role of
the university and technology has
enabled universities to move beyond the
education of elites of highly selected
elites to the world and I think that's
incredibly powerful I'd love to ask
about a challenging decision you had to
face kind of at the end of your time at
Yale you sorry I'm staying up to you oh
yeah you were you know one of the
hardest things that you had to deal with
that your end of your tenure Yale was
expanding the residential college system
and obviously running into the financial
crisis the economics of that became
challenging yep it was rumored that one
of the other view for the top speakers
offered a very large gift in order to
you know name one of those colleges
after that person and it was rumored
that Yale turned that down I realize
that that conversation is probably
confidential and don't want to have to
delve too much into that but can you
talk a little bit about the challenge
that you have as an executive between
profitability and kind of organizational
values and how you think that situation
potentially exemplifies that and how you
think about that at Coursera as you
obviously deal with the number of kind
of important morals and values in
education but also needing to drive
profitability good question
so you know we we had we put a lot of
money into our facilities and there's
only
after we got the campus mostly renovated
that we decided that expansion would be
a good idea and you know if you know the
Yale system we have these very
particularly since they've been
renovated amazing facilities for house
undergraduates that are that create
social environments and great
communities and have an amazing you know
facilities to support that we wanted to
build two more there was high high on
the agenda right before the crisis hit
and along with a lot of other capital
projects that we just basically froze at
that point I I won't confirm or deny the
the rumor you heard but I will say this
I think that we basically committed it
decided at the time of the financial
crisis that if we're gonna go forward
with the colleges we're gonna have to
raise a hundred percent of the money we
we're gonna have to be essentially an
all-cash transaction we weren't going to
take new debt to finance the new
colleges and we have to absorb the
incremental operating costs in our
operating budget we have to have enough
you know projected future surplus that
we could do that so well it was we're
not going to rob anything existing in
order to in order to expand there's no
question that had we wanted to allow
donors to name these colleges we
probably could have raised a
substantially greater we're naming
towers and and courtyards and entryways
but the the names of the Yale colleges
you know originally were selected by the
Yale Corporation to honor you know
important founders of the university or
great Yale
you know Yale were these great great
great citizens and contributors to
public life or intellectual life who
came from Yale and my board did not want
a name of college for a donor and I have
to say I
I was very ambivalent actually on that
subject personally because I really
wanted to see this project go forward
and we have lots of things named for
donors and you know but I mean I saw the
argument and I and it was pretty
overwhelmingly
I mean the Yale corporation which is a
small very highly deliberative body was
pretty strong about this and so we had
to disappoint at least one prospective
donor I maybe I guess they nested the
general question is yes there's always a
tension that beats between values and
Pratt and practicality but I have to say
at an institution like Yale the choice
comes down on the side of values way
more often than not and and and actually
I would say this is probably more
salient for all of you take it out of
the Yale context I mean one of the
things I always ask myself it whenever
we had a tough issue
any-any tough issue was what is the
right thing to do I mean that is you can
make all kinds of expedient arguments on
one side or another and it's the
temptations when you're running a big
institution like Yale because it is so
much in the public view and so much of
what you do is scrutinized by so many
different people there's always a
temptation to say oh this is one we can
sort of hide we don't have to deal with
it we can shove it under the rug you
can't you just can't there's nothing
nothing gets shoved under the rug I mean
basically you have to assume I live my
life like I had to assume that
everything I did or said could appear in
the New York Times I mean you just you
just you can't hide anything so you
might as well live by your values
because in the long run that's the best
way to live I still I still feel that
way it's just it's a little it's a it
the the profit motive in it means that
one of your objectives at least is you
know to make some you've got to be
sustainable you've got to bring returns
to you to your owners that's but that's
a value that also has to be weighed
against the mission you you know we
haven't decided at Coursera to become a
beef
operation but a company like Coursera is
certainly a candidate for that because
we do have a mission which is to deliver
you know to deliver universal access to
the world's best education and we all
believe in it and we wouldn't have had
we wouldn't have succeeded in getting
the great employees that we have managed
to attract without that mission we were
just another ed tech startup with you
know wanted to make a lot of money I
don't think we would have got where
we're competing with Google and Facebook
for engineers some of our senior execs
have left companies like Google Facebook
Netflix to come join us so you know and
and there they were they're out there
they're really not there because they
think they're gonna get rich I mean we
may all get rich but that's not what
that's not why we're there we're there
because we think this is a really
important mission a question from this
side
well yeah so let's start with why you
should still pay two years of acting war
my daughter took an engineering degree
too so and I paid a lot of undergraduate
tuitions at Stanford for you know three
times for so and I'd pay it them and and
and and it's still worth it because what
you get in the live experience with such
amazing fellow students and and with the
live contact with mentors and professors
in we're not gonna be able to supply
that on the internet anytime soon I mean
what we're making available and
democratizing is essentially the content
so if you want to master content the of
Coursera is a great tool I if you want
to you know really do a deep dive into
forming relationships that are gonna
mean something to you for a lifetime if
to learn all the soft skills and and and
interpersonal skills and skills of
leadership and followership and teamwork
that you need in life there's nothing
like these great universities there's
just no experience comparable it's a
this is an immersion experience with a
lot of brilliant people you know who
have enormous potential to do great
things in the world and you get to
benefit from it that's what it's worth
many times what you pay for it actually
so-so I don't think you know GSB if is
going down down anytime soon
to the internet I'm not worried about
that so I think you know I think the
things are I think it can be reconciled
now the the question does come up what
happened but what about the experiences
that really aren't like this so what
about what about second tier third tier
institutions that basically our
residential art don't have communities
people commute in to a community college
to take a course and they go home I mean
could the internet you know could
critical Coursera replace that I think
the answer is yes it could you know
could become a cheaper more effective
way to learn to learn what
students having that kind of experience
can learn so there yes it will have
caused some kind of disruption and there
will be some just some just relocation
of of students toward just getting
credentials online rather than getting
degrees how massive a change it will be
over what timeframe I'm my guess is
moderate and over a long time for him
rather than a lots and over a short one
another question from Twitter sure this
one's from Gabe Elizondo and it touches
on something you just mentioned a little
bit that the disruption of higher ed is
going very slowly and you've seen that
overtime is the main missing ingredient
the student interaction that you just
spoke about and if so how do you feel
about sort of hybrid models like the
Minerva project or other companies that
might be trying to combine mass
education with those student student
engagement models yeah well Minerva is
that he said that's ultra small scale
that's not so that's a that's a
different that's using both online and
in live methods but for a very highly
selective group so that's I think
different the III think yeah the missing
pizza's so far or not it's it's it's the
it's the network effects of bringing
everybody together in one physical
location that which is both peer-to-peer
learning and and learning social skills
and it's also critical thinking because
the classroom experience which could be
replicated online I think with live
video chat but that would have to be
small scale
I mean you I don't think you could have
2,000 students online and do the and and
and do the kind of critical thinking
tool development that sort of the the
questioning the forcing you to defend an
argument I mean that's very personalized
then it works very well in a 15-person
seminar works even better in an Oxford
tutorial but but the the these are not
the things that that the internet can
replicate so it's so it's it's a number
it's the you know it's the res it's the
it's the it's the whole residential on
campus experience that's a big part of
it and
and it's the intimate contact with
faculty and it's the and it's the highly
interactive classroom all of all of
those are ingredients of what you get
into the week we are not delivering now
I think the technology could deliver
some of that but not all of them sorry
can you stand up in yeah are you the
question is how do you help how can you
help companies and emerging markets to
decipher what are the courses that might
be valuable to them and yeah yeah this
is a work in progress but it's something
we're very mindful of and and so so yes
we've talked to a couple of large global
companies that employ people around the
world and try to elicit from them what
kinds of courses are valuable what I
expect will happen hasn't happened yet
but I'd love to see actually on our site
a kind of posting that you know
PricewaterhouseCoopers recommends that's
a global company that has over a million
employees worldwide recommends these
five courses or these ten courses these
would be useful to up to us I mean and I
and I you know we've had conversations
with some of some of the corporations
about this and I think I think we'll get
there in the next year probably have
some of that and that'll be a helpful
guide postie I mean basically allow
companies to to demonstrate you know the
Indy indicate what courses they want
obviously they can do it in their job
wrecks as well so but you know actually
posting guide posts on her site would
have externalities because if a PwC says
that's the value of course for us a
smaller accounting firm and you know in
Latin America could could look at that
and say yeah that's that makes sense to
us
- well we're about to run out of time
Rick but I do want to end with one
question that I think will will speak to
a lot of people in the audience because
it's on the GSB application and that
question is what matters most to you and
why I'm tempted to say that the Giants
win the World Series because I'm a
lifelong fan but that's that would be
frivolous when I got appointed actually
a little sideline when I got appointed
president of Yale I was asked by the New
York Times is this the most exciting day
of your life and I responded no not as
exciting as when the Giants moved to San
Francisco I was 11 years old my wife
almost killed me with that I mean yeah
birth of our children there are some
things more important but what matters
me to me I you know it may it may sound
trivial and try it and it could be said
by many people but making making a
difference in the world I mean doing I
come out of a you know a tradition I had
a mother who raised me to sort of
understand you know you're a person with
a good mind and you have an obligation
you know to make a difference in the
world I mean do something of value to
others so I'd say that's what matters to
me well thank you so much Rick